have some very special guests from do
the right thing st. Louis captain Steven
Miller and Lieutenant Kimberly Allen and
they are with Maurice Ashley yes we
always love it to have a guest like this
on our show from do the right thing
which I think it's a nice little title
there's a spike Lee joint I think
there's a reference there yes captain
Steven Miller and lieutenant Kimberly
Alan welcome to the show you do the
right thing is involved in all kinds of
wonderful initiatives but tell us a
little bit about your organization well
we started in 1994 as an independent
chapter of a program that began in
Florida and our purpose is to recognize
positive behavior we're tired of seeing
the bad kids get all the publicity the
ones that do the the bad crimes that we
all see about on the news it's time that
we highlight what the good kids are
doing the positive examples that they're
setting for their peers and that's what
we're all about now we see some great
images here I know you've been involved
with the chest cops program as well tell
us that Kimberly share some of the
stories that have happened that stand
out in your mind well for example the
one young man who started our he was the
reason we started a Student of the Year
program he he lives in rural Missouri
his initial dealing with do the right
thing excuse me have a cold the
springtime cold his initial dealing with
do the right thing he heard his
grandfather yelling for help
his father kind of dismissed it said no
he's okay let's finish our work it he
said he was persistent and said no we
need to go check on grandpa grandpa
actually had a round bale of hay fall on
him and he was able to save his
grandfather's life in turn a bit later
his father got pinned in a and a pinned
by a bull and actually got injured quite
severely by the bull and the young man
was able to put the tractor in between
his father and the bull to get his
father out of there and get him to a
safe place unfortunately his father's to
come to injuries but he wasn't able to
get his father up to the family so they
could all say their goodbyes and you
know we recognized him as our student of
the year for you don't come across
things
that very often so there's a really
touching story
tell us why HS why you ma have a chest
now Ches has become very popular
especially in the st. Louis area and
I've noticed throughout my 36 year
career that it's always been popular in
some of the poorer areas of the city and
we particularly serve those areas
through the st. Louis Public School
System and with the cops and chess
program already with the public schools
and what we do in the public schools
trying to encourage positive behavior
such as chess it looks like a natural
fit to us to help each other out
that's wonderful I've been part of the
Van Deventer delinquency juvenile
delinquency Center visiting there and
showing them how to play chess have had
a great time I will be going back again
right after this tournament is over
it's almost where are you seeing some of
these kids that you've impacted where
are they now
I mean you know we see them through high
school captain Miller and I were just
speaking we would like to eventually
fund a a type of scholarship we haven't
had the funding for that quite yet but
but we follow them and then and they
continue their positive behaviors
through their high school years and you
we get to follow some through pauses
some of them are repeat winners so not
only do they continue that they get
recognized for their initial behavior
but they continue said behavior to
another award later on down the line and
I think it's important to note that
every kid that's nominated regardless of
how minor or petty the nomination might
seem every kid is a winner everyone
receives one of our t-shirts
certificate of recognition and some food
gift certificates then we have ten whose
stories we pick out of the hundreds we
receive every month that we recognize at
a special ceremony and this the ceremony
is attended by either the area police
chiefs are their representatives and
charity Friant comes and actually emcees
the program channel 4 puts that it on
their website they also have a spot
where the channel where the kids are
waving so all their family members get
to see them be right
for doing the right thing as well that's
wonderful tell us which website we can
send of folks to you can go to do the
right thing STL org or you can go to our
Facebook page facebook.com slash DT RT
Destiel wonderful wonderful work we
appreciate you in the word that you do
in the community captain Steven Miller
and lieutenant - Kimberly Allen doing
great work in st. Louis as chess gets
more popular we're happy to be a part of
their vision